I want you to meet Henrietta Lacks, who's
had a hand in changing medical biology and
genetics for the better, even today. I want to
share with you a short version of the
story of Henrietta Lacks. But the longer version
is documented in detail in Rebecca Skloot's 2010
book, The Immortal Life of Henrietta Lacks. In
1951, Henrietta was unknowingly suffering from cervical cancer.
After admission and treatment at the only hospital in the proximity that would
admit black patients, Johns Hopkins Hospital. Two
samples of Henrietta's cervix tissue were removed.
Including a cancerous portion without her permission.
Although Henrietta died on October 4th, 1951,
due to her metastasized cancer, the cells from the tissue biopsy from her cervix
continued to be grown in the lab to
this day. Known as HeLa cells, He for Henrietta
and La for Lacks. They were the first human
cells that scientists could keep growing in the lab
long enough to start actually doing real research.
Most human cells would grow for a few days
and then die, but HeLa cells kept growing and
growing. As a result, the cells were commercialized and
distributed all over the world. HeLa cells were
used in the development of the Salk vaccine
for Polio. HeLa cells have also been used
for cancer research, AIDS research, gene mapping and
countless other amazing medical advances. And in the
spring of 2013, finally, the genome sequence of
HeLa cells was published for the whole world
to see. In return for the outrageous contributions
of HeLa cells, despite the fact that they were taken
and used without the consent of Henrietta herself. What compensation do
you think's been provided to her family over the years
since her death? Do you think that there's a multimillion dollar
trust fund, that's been sent from labs and pharmaceutical companies
all over the world that used HeLa cells for discoveries? Or
do you think that 0.1% of all profits from biotech
companies that use HeLa cells go to the family every year?
Or is there $1 million that was paid in a lump sum just
once to the family from the NIH? Or is it that $50,000 was paid
to each family member, from the Johns
Hopkins Hospital, where the cells were originally
isolated? Or do you think that there's
been no real financial compensation at all?